Sailor Arnold R Fesser in 1944
The t-shirt
is arguably the most popular outer garment
in the entire world.
Coming in a range of styles, colors and sizes
there is quite literally a t-shirt for everyone.
But where did this iconic garment come from
and how did it become so popular?
Relatively speaking, the t-shirt is a fairly
new addition to our collective wardrobes and
it has only been an acceptable piece of clothing
in its own right for around half a century.
While the garment itself has existed in a
recognisable form (albeit with wider necks
and shorter sleeves) since the early 20th
century, it was almost universally considered
to be underwear and it was rarely, if ever
worn in public.
So where did the t-shirt come from?
It’s thought that it evolved from a kind
of all-in-one underwear made from red flannel
known as the “union suit” which was popular
with workers in the 19th century.
The union suit was patented in 1868 in New
York and was based on a similar kind of underwear
that had been popular with Victorian women.
While the Union Suit excelled at keeping men
warm, it was all but useless at keeping them
cool in hot weather, unless that is, it was
cut in half, which many workers did.
In so doing, they inadvertently created the
top half of what many would recognise today
as “Long Johns”, a similar garment which
consisted of two pieces of long underwear.
Men's-Union-SuitAlthough Long Johns themselves
have existed since the 17th century where
they were similarly popular with workers and
the poor, they were most popular during the
Victorian Era, along with Union Suits, where
they were advertised to women as a way to
keep their waists trim, via having to wear
fewer layers around the waist, while still
keeping warm.
Unlike Union Suits which have since become
the literal butt of many a comedy gag (thanks
to the fact they often feature a built-in
flap on the butt), Long Johns have never really
waned in popularity since and have been keeping
people warm right up until the modern day.
Sometime in the 19th century, the people making
these type of toasty undergarments began experimenting
with fabrics that could stretch back into
shape to make the product more comfortable.
This resulted in the creation of buttonless
undershirts made from wool and cotton that
you could pull over your head without ruining
the collar.
Though the exact date these so-called pullovers
were invented, by whom and when workers began
wearing them isn’t known, we do know that
they absolutely weren’t considered something
you could wear in your day-to-day life without
something over them.
There were even laws on the books as early
as 1890 in places like Havana stating that
it was illegal to wear these pullover tops
exposed in public.
The fate of what would become the t-shirt
began to change in 1904, when the Cooper Underwear
Company began marketing them to single men
as “bachelor undershirts” with a tagline
that simply read: “No safety pins — no
buttons — no needle — no thread”
The advertisement played up to the fact that
the “undershirt”, as it was then known,
consisted of a single piece of fabric that
had no buttons, meaning it would be more durable
than its buttoned counterpart, with less maintenance.
Why is this important to the history of the
t-shirt?
Because very shortly after this advertisement
ran (about a year), the US Navy, who employed
many a young bachelor with limited sewing
skills, officially incorporated the button-less
white undershirt into its uniform.
According to the (1905) Uniform Regulations
of the United States Navy, a full transcript
of which you can read here, the cotton undershirt
was exactly that- a shirt that had to be worn
underneath the rest of the sailor’s uniform.
That’s not to say there weren’t exceptions
though; according to the regulations, sailors
were allowed to wear a light cotton undershirt
“of identical pattern” in warm weather
at the discretion of their commanding officer
whilst sailors working the engine room were
allowed to fashion themselves a makeshift
undershirt to make themselves more comfortable
if they so desired.
The undershirt came to the attention of the
US Army a few years later during WWI with
the undershirts soon worn by tens of thousands
of army soldiers, many of whom took the fashion
home with them.
Shortly after WWI ended in 1920, the author
F.Scott Fitzgerald became the first known
person to use the word “t-shirt” in print
when he included it in his novel, This Side
of Paradise as one of the items the main character
takes with him to university.
And, in fact, a very slight tweak on the design
of early t-shirts came about at university,
the invention of the “crew-neck t-shirt”.
These were made in 1932 by Jockey International
Inc at the bequest of the University of South
California, who wanted a lightweight, absorbent
garment its football players could wear underneath
their jerseys to prevent their pads from rubbing
and chafing.
The resulting style t-shirt was a huge hit
with the team and it wasn’t long before
students began popularly wearing them.
By the time WWII started, the “modern”
t-shirt had become commonplace in high schools
and universities across the states, though
it wasn’t yet ubiquitous and was still commonly
worn by adults, at least, as an undershirt.
(There were many exceptions, of course, particular
among laborers in hot environments, such as
farmers.)
The final push for mainstream acceptance of
the t-shirt as an outer garment started at
the end of WWII, when soldiers returning home
began incorporating them into their casual
wardrobe, much in the same way they’d done
during the war.
The popularity of a t-shirt as an outer garment
further surged thanks to Marlon Brando and
his role as Stanley Kowalski in A Street Car
Named Desire which featured Brando wearing
a tight fitting (as most were at this point),
bicep caressing t-shirt.
Brando’s smouldering performance in both
the play and 1951 movie caused a nationwide
spike in sales of t-shirts, proving to the
world that the t-shirt could be a “sexy,
stand-alone, outer-wear garment“.
It didn’t take that long after for businesses
to realise the marketing potential of these
mostly blank outer garments, with the likes
of Roy Rogers and Walt Disney among many others
soon using them for this purpose, popularizing
the now ubiquitous practice of putting designs
on t-shirts.
And
the rest, as they say, is history.